it's a pleasure to be here thanks for
thanks for attending I'm glad there
aren't people who are sitting on the
floor though for us so yeah my name is
Willis Sharon I'm I'm not quite a
recovering PhD student actually I'm
still in my in the very last last
section of my studies but I cannot wait
to finish but it's been oh it has been a
fun journey so today I'm I'm going to
talk more about sort of the method of
more of a methodological theme about
sensitivity analysis and why it's
important but first a few sort of
definitions I'm going to be talking
about uncertainty and specifically
uncertainty for the and the application
of uncertainty in simulation and
optimization models so these are models
which actually should have represent
some kind of physical or engineering or
or any kind of process so those those
quite a lot of interest in the in the PI
data conference in sort of in
uncertainty and Bayesian methods and you
can do sensitivity analysis within a
Bayesian framework and within so for
example pi MC yesterday if anyone else
was in the tutorial looking at um base
analysis of sports stats but the library
I'm going to present doesn't really go
into this so I'm not going to present on
that if you're interested in simulation
models and trying to understand models
that's that's what I am going to cover
today so you split the talk into really
three parts firstly I'm going to try and
and convince you why sensitivity
analysis is a good idea give you some
kind of context and then I'll give you
some real-world examples of how I view
sensitivity analysis in my work and how
others others have and then I'm going to
briefly present the library and I'm
basically going to go through one of the
one of the examples that are available
and the on the github repository and try
and sell the library to you
so really sensitivity analysis is
motivated by this idea that if you're
using a model to try and make an
inference about something you want to
yet you want to make some kind of or get
some kind of insight about the real
world that insight is worth much less if
you have to make a very narrow set of
assumptions so a fragile inference is
not worth taking seriously you want to
make you want to obtain robust insights
from your model and sensitivity analysis
can help you do that it allows you to
corroborate a model so if you have a
simulation model of some real-world
process it's it's always going to be
wrong but it can be useful to quote
George box and sensitivity analysis can
help help that process you can test the
ability of the model to represent that
you explained in the real world but in a
very simple as simple away as possible
you can build confidence in the results
of the obtain from these model you can
judge the quality of the model and so on
it also allows you to focus development
of a model so you can work out what are
the most important parts of the model
and then concentrate on that so what is
sensitivity analysis allows you to
quantify the degree to which a model
input affects the output of a model so
even if you're just given a simulation
model of an optimized optimization model
as a black box you can assess which
inputs are most important for the
outputs and generally these approaches
are split into two different camps you
have local approaches and local
approaches so if you've made a simple
say financial spreadsheet model you've
probably used a local approach if you've
examined you know how the interest rate
affects your your the net present value
of an investment for example and you do
that just by increasing it or decreasing
it and say okay what seems to be seems
to be quite important and you may
compare that with another
another input so that's a local approach
a global approach starts varying all of
the inputs to a model at the same time
tries to explore the global input space
of the model and quantify the effects of
that upon the output in a rigorous and
structured way and these are the
approaches that I'm going to present on
which we sort of incorporated into their
sensitivity analysis library so what can
you obtain from a sensitivity analysis
there are three sort of main settings
for a sensitivity analysis so you can
work out which of the inputs are most
important which should you really focus
focus on you can work out which factors
or which inputs are unimportant so which
can you safely ignore without without
compromising the the outputs you get
from the model and you can also look at
if you're just interested in say a risk
model we can look at the particular
portion of the output space of the model
and try and work out which inputs are
most important for just influencing that
that sort of threshold effect for
example and there are different there
are different approaches for all of
these so a few examples so this is
actually an example from John Herrmann
so he was John is based in the States
hence the transatlantic collaboration
and he's interested in watershed models
so these are models of hydrological
systems in in valleys trying to quantify
our quantifies say the risk of flood
events are given certain rainfall
patterns and he's done how you use these
techniques to look at which inputs to
these models are most important over
time
another example the this is based on
more sort of looking at robustness of of
events and he's using factor mapping so
trying to work out which factors are
most important in terms of the
reliability the frequency of worst cases
and so on worst case costs he's also
looked at using a factor priority as a
prioritization setting looking at which
which of the inputs to these models the
most most important and they generally
sort of cooperated with one another and
in my work I'm looking at a large energy
system optimization model I'm looking at
well I'm trying to understand which of
the technologies or other inputs to the
model are most important as I'm using a
factor prioritization using Morris so
all of these words Sabo Morris and these
are all different methods that are
available in the library and they all
have different characteristics so
generally you have to think about
normally running our simulation model is
computationally expensive if it was very
cheap then you could just run you could
look at every single possible
combination of inputs and do a very
thorough analysis but in reality that's
never possible and so you would recourse
to one of these techniques so the
advantage of these techniques is that
they they all work on any type of model
so if your model is nonlinear or
non-additive then these techniques rule
are good and won't end up with or won't
give you spurious results given this
they all differ in the sort of amount of
information you need to run them so if
you have probability distributions to
your inputs or if you can just really
come up with a range to quantify the
uncertainty in your it
in your inputs and some of them can deal
with correlated like a joint
distribution for your inputs and some
rely on an assumption of Independence
between all of the inputs and they will
have a different computational cost
okay so si lid is a library written in
pure Python it's available on pi PI and
you can install it using pip or set up
tools and you can run our unit tests
using setup tools as well
pythons a table top PI test and the
github repository is under John's
account at the moment but we're going to
move it to an organizational account
because it's beginning to gain a bit
more sort of momentum and being used
throughout the academic fields so when
you run a sensitivity analysis normally
would have you've gone through the
process of develop developing your model
so say let's come up with an example
like a simple financial accounting model
should we invest in I mean if I work in
energy so I'll give you a energy example
should we put solar PV panels on our
roof you come up with a simple
spreadsheet model to work out the
payback time and then think about all of
the different sources of income and
costs that you may incur and receive so
incomes from this example would be the
feed-in tariff from the government so
you get a subsidy for each kilowatt hour
of energy that you export from your
solar panels solar irradiance changes
over time it's an uncertain variable it
might you might have a sunnier year or a
less than a year and the rate at which
you can borrow money to invest in these
solar panels would also be uncertain so
you could build a simple spreadsheet
model to look at this and determine
whether you should invest and you you
run a sort of net present value type
approach and say well if the net present
value is greater than zero then you
would invest you'll get some kind of
payback if it's less than zero than you
two best so now we can do a simple or if
we just did a one at a time local
sensitivity analysis we take each of
those uncertain inputs one at a time put
them up and down and say well given our
uncertainty in these this one or this
one seems to be more or less important
of course that we want to do a more
thorough analysis because we have the
tools and so reduce global sensitivity
analysis approach using the sensitivity
analysis library so the steps are as
follows given our model we define a
parameter file this service defines our
inputs and the ranges that we assigned
to the inputs we then generate a sample
and this is a structured sample
depending on which approach we're going
to use and then we put these this sample
through the model and we run the model
many times and the sort of Monte Carlo
type approach and then given the inputs
and the output inputs to the model the
outputs from the model you can then
compute some sensitivity indices we
compute the result metrics so the
following example just uses the method
of Morris but if you recall from the
buzzer our method slide so we have the
robots there are five different
techniques that we've used under
different circumstances so the syntax is
pretty much the same and it's very
simple but you can just use the
different methods using the same syntax
so we define our parameter file and you
can either use the library from the
command line or you can use it within
Python so if you've written on a
simulation model within Python it's very
easy to implement this this with this
sensitivity analysis techniques with
your model but you can also use it if
the model is written in anything else
you'll just need to work out how to get
the data from our sample into your model
and you could easily write that into
to base or into Excel or wherever you
are using it or whatever you're using so
you define your parameter file and it's
pretty straightforward
it's either it so within Python you're
just you make a parameter dictionary
based on this syntax or you could just
write a text file which is each
parameter on a different line and then
the lower and upper bound associated
with the range over which their
parameter would would move and then you
generate the sample it's just one line
on the command line or one line of code
and then you run your model so that
maybe in Excel and then again one line
of code run the analysis
and then you can view your results the
results do differ depending or the
actual result metrics differ depending
on the method you are using so this is
the method of Morris so mu star here is
the mean of the variation in the output
given the variation of each input and
Sigma is the standard deviation of that
variation in the output so this gives
you I mean the morris analysis gives you
insights not only into which is the most
important parameter which in this case
is x1 but it also tells you which which
parameters interact with other
parameters and that's given by Sigma so
so x1 is the most important parameter
but it's also interacts with other
parameters or is highly nonlinear and
you can plot these parameters in
different ways
so future work at the moment we have
quite quite a lot of interest from other
academics in in the library as far as I
know we're one of the only or the only
Python library to do sensitivity
analysis and our aim is really to bring
this to to the masses you know these
sensitivity analysis techniques are
really powerful they're considerably
better than the alternative one at a
time approaches and the fundamental idea
behind the library is to make it as easy
as possible to do this just one line of
code we'd like to add a visualizations
module just to plot these results in a
nicer way and also to improve
accessibility for non academics so quite
a lot of this is based on on fairly
dense academic papers which which I've
read a lot of and we're continually
updating the algorithms and the
formulations underlying the library but
there's no reason why non-academic scan
couldn't use this as well there's also
lots of opportunities for avid coders to
optimize our code I'm a first and
foremost a PhD student and not a
software engineer we're gradually
improving our the quality of the code
and incorporating unit tests and so on
the yeah if anyone's interested in
reading more about sensitivity analysis
and I strongly recommend this book
global sensitivity analysis the primer
just by Italian guy called Sal telly and
yeah thanks to everyone at UCL you can
access the repository here on our github
account and also thanks very much to
John Hammond for his example slides and
yeah for starting off the sensitivity
analysis library
okay that's going slightly outside my I
could I could give you an answer for
Bayesian statistics for example so there
are there are Bayesian techniques which
allow you to look at the value of
information so you can actually quantify
the value of improving or of getting a
better probability distribution to
represent your beliefs so obtaining more
knowledge and you can quantify the
actual value of that so that allows you
to basically identify which which
assumption you've made so should you
improve your priors should you do more
training of your model and there are
techniques which allow which will tell
you well yeah where to focus your
efforts and that's that's a sort of
fundamental rationale for doing
sensitivity analysis so this is this is
the approach for simulation optimization
models you can do the same for Bayesian
maybe you can do the same for machine
learning and I guess so
yeah yeah so depending on the sure okay
so the question is I was presenting
results from the method of Morris and I
said the Sigma gives you information
about interaction or nonlinearities can
I not distinguish between the two so the
answer is with the method of Morris you
cannot distinguish between the two it's
a very computationally efficient
approach but it doesn't give you that
enough amor that much information which
may be ok for some for some for the
factor fixing for example we thought if
you just want to screen out the
unimportant variables then you don't
really need to know whether you know
what's interacting with what however if
you take what we call the cell tele of
Cibola approach it's a lot more
computationally intensive but you can
look at each pairwise interaction and
also higher order interactions between
all of the inputs so that allows you to
tell to quantify exactly how much
interaction is going on between two or
more parameters as well as the total
effects so the basically the conditional
variance in the output given the
variation in each individual input
yeah you may yeah yeah okay there are
some that are quite tricky yeah to to do
you may end up with an issue we're
actually all of your parameters are
equally important that's quite uncommon
normally very few a minority of the
parameters or input parameters are very
important and explain most of the
variation in the model output and the
remainder are much less important okay
so how does the how do the approaches
scale they scowl reasonably well and I
can show you in my maybe I think it's
coming on I think this one to sleep yeah
okay okay so the question was how does
the how do the approaches scale so this
line here tells you the computational
cost of the approaches so if you have
hundreds of features you can actually
start grouping them and you can that
allows you to reduce the dimensionality
of the initial problem and you can take
a staged approach so I'm using models
with many hundreds of input parameters
so I use a Morris grouped approach which
we've which is available in the library
you just group the parameters in the
parameter file you run the approach if
there are any groups of parameters which
are deemed to be very important then you
can split those out group the
unimportant parameters into one mega
group and doing a more detailed analysis
on just those and then once you're
pretty confident that those grouped
factors are unimportant you can then fix
them and then you could do a more
detailed analysis like a Saab all fast
and our sister to get a lot more
information about those
most important parameters so depending
on how computationally costly your model
is to run then that would that would
dictate your choice of the number of
inputs you do how much you group them
and which approach you use cool okay if
there's no more questions so just we
come up